guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
20 pennies for me
for me or for the poor people
hello who's that it's me
[Laughter]
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
hey this is a special caller
hello who's that it's me
hello who's you
what is your name aaliyah yes
is it and who is your baba's name ali
what do you have are you going to be
giving how much are you going to give
today because last time you called you
said a million pounds
you said you're going to give 20 pounds
i will give you 20 pounds
for me for me or for the poor people
but yes for me okay you know what elia
okay bubba's gonna give 20 pounds so
should we make it 40 pounds
yes for the poor people
okay no problem those i like to speak
different languages you don't understand
but i do what i try to do anyways
so 20 pounds from you and the family and
20 pounds from me
that's 40 pounds can you say tuck beard
[Applause]
are you happy now
you don't need to tell everybody about
that you want to speak
she wants a present i don't get it
that's that's what she says but if i do
get it
i love you so much